- So the President called a
meeting with Sidney Powell
and Rudy Giuliani, amongst others
to discuss Sidney Powell
becoming special counsel
to the White House in
charge of election fraud.
Also at the meeting,
they discussed issuing an executive order
to seize voting machines
and potentially using
the military to, I guess,
redo the election.
So the President is in
full Leeroy Jenkins mode,
but there's good news and
bad news about Sidney Powell
as special counsel.
Number one, this may
or may not be a Mueller-type
special counsel.
It may just be a post
created at the White House
and as bonkers as that is,
National Security
Counselor Kel McClanahan,
who is also the lawyer
for Legal Eagle points out
that basically zero oversight,
FOIA wouldn't apply until 2025
if they don't destroy the
records on the way out.
But if she got a security clearance,
she'd have to go through the
same pre-publication review
that John Bolton did.
So Merry Christmas, everyone.
But if you'd like some real holiday cheer,
check out this video I
did on all the laws broken
in "National Lampoon's
Christmas Vacation".
And I'll see you in court.